- So wait, when did
y'all's friendship start?
- Well, we have a pretty cute story,
I think.
- [Kelly] Aww.
- This is our meeting story.
(all laughing)
- We were looking at photos
- Oh, you mean when we auditioned together
- When we auditioned together.
We were looking at photos
of ourselves from the red carpet
and we were like, are we getting married?
Is this our engagement?
- Yeah we were like,
holding hands.
- Literally Kaley was like kissing me -
- I was kissing her, I'm
like, what's what am I doing?
- It's a little insane.
But yeah, I went in to go
chemistry read for, with her
for "Flight Attendant"
and I walked in and there was everyone
and their mother was in a room this size.
- By the way back story, we
had read so many for Annie.
- Yeah, that's intimidating.
- Like, so many we could not
find my best friend.
- It was intimidating.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- We couldn't find it.
- It was definitely, yeah,
I mean, I'd never met her
and I'm -
- Yeah, we'd never met.
I'm pretty good with auditions.
I don't get super crazy
nervous, but you walk in
and there's like 12 people on a tiny couch
and they're like, hi,
it's so nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Don't fail.
- Don't (beep).
You're like, okay.
(Kelly laughing)
And yeah, we had this one
scene that we needed to read
and they were like, feel
free to improv a little.
And you're like, okay.
And we started the scene and
Kaley was supposed to come up,
she was late and I was
supposed to be mad at her
and she was supposed to
come up and be like, hi.
And she went, you wanna do it?
- I went oh, it's, boop, boop.
- And I was like, don't do that.
And I smacked her hand
away and we always say that
in that moment, our friendship was born.
- That's where the chemistry ignited.
- [Zosia] Yes, yes.
- [Kaley] Yeah.
- And now we -
- She's still "Boop" in my phone.
- And now -
- [Kelly] She's still "Boop"?
- Yeah, she's still "Boop" in my phone.
- I actually didn't know
that until yesterday.
I was sending myself photos
from her phone and I
was like, am I "Boop"?
- I was like,
how did you not know that?
- And she was like, yeah,
you're "Boop".
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I love that y'all started like that.
I love that kind of improv though.
That's where that chemistry was created,
that's cool.
- It was a major improv.
In fact, when she left,
they were like, okay,
it's obvious you guys are
friends and you knew each other.
And I was like,
we've never met before.
- We've never met.
- It was really built in the room.
And through season one, we
obviously got very close, but,
on a different level, season two,
and we also share a love for horses,
and so we ride horses together.
Yeah, and so we just had
all these things in common
but we definitely got closer this year
and we've just become
inseparable, and I love it
'cause in this season, you
literally see our friendship.
It couldn't be more real.
- Yeah.
- I love y'all's friendship
on this show
- Thank you.
- It's so fun -
and your characters could
not be more different.
- Oh correct, yeah.
- Which is like friendship.
So, yeah, you're always Ann.
That's why I don't know if we'd work out.
- I think we'd be great.
- Would we help each other?
- Too much.
- Or would we dive
in together?
- We would just encourage
each other.
It would be like flames,
being like -
- I'm not sure Kaley.
- I love it.
- I'm willing to try.
So it seemed like that y'all
really kept it light though,
'cause it's a lot of
serious stuff going on
but y'all kept it light on set.
I know that y'all like to do,
let's just talk about this.
What was this?
- Oh, the prank wars
that we had.
That's my set bathroom,
covered in fake cockroaches.
- This is also
an apartment complex in Texas.
(Kaley laughing)
- Or New York.
- This is also Fort Worth,
Texas, an apartment that I grew
up in when I was a kid.
- Or Manhattan.
When you see it and they're like,
so this is $7,500 a month.
- But the size,
the size of cockroaches.
- Can you believe, so we became,
it really became prank wars on set.
I encouraged it because I really hoped,
I love pranking people.
I was unable to prank anyone on this show.
- Well -
- They just kept pranking me.
- I have to give some backstory.
We literally started out the season
and Kaley basically was
like, I wanna tell everyone,
I'm gonna scare you all.
- I shouldn't have said that.
- And you're gonna be
crying for your mother.
I'm gonna scare you so bad.
And she was like, I am so good at this.
Get ready and everyone be on your toes.
- Kiss of death.
Why did I do that?
- I don't know.
- So they all were like,
Kaley don't, just you'll know
she's gonna do something.
No one ever got scared of me.
- And she, I mean those
cockroaches, she purchased, on -
- I bought those
to prank other people.
- She bought those
- [Kelly] They used -
- Yes!
That's amazing.
- They used my prank against me,
- Against herself.
- That's kind of cool.
That's inception,
I like it.
- It's ridiculous.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And also, in your defense,
it was an entire casting crew against one.
She was like, I'm gonna get you guys.
And then it was, and
also people were like,
oh, should we try and scare Kaley?
She's walking out of the stages right now,
and they'd like -
And Kaley would be like -
- [Kaley] All on
their walkies.
(Zosia screaming)
- [Zosia] I mean, the videos.
- [Kelly] I scare so easily.
- I do too.
- Yes, we do too.
- I hate it, I hate it.
Wait, so what happened?
Is this your car?
Kaley, is this what happened here?
- Oh yes, they covered my car, let's see.
- [Zosia] Oh the Post-its?
- [Kaley] That's about 2000
Post-its, that was on wrap day.
- And I also wanna know how sad were you
that you needed three bears?
Like, what's happening?
- [Kaley] Isn't that so sad?
I needed many more than that, that day.
Yeah, actually funny,
so that bear actually does
come up in season two.
They put like 50 of those in my car.
So I had 50 bears.
- Oh my God, I love it.
- So you'll see that in
the middle of season two,
but yeah, that's about 2000 Post-it notes.
My entire crew.
- [Kelly] I love this.
- [Kaley] It's kind of
brilliant and it's very pretty.
- [Zosia] It is, I mean -
- [Kaley] Look at these crazy people.
They are insane.
- [Kelly] They took the time.
- [Kaley] They took the time.
- [Zosia] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You gotta respect that.
- [Kaley] Oh, mega respect.
- The long game, yeah.
- Mega respect.
- How long did it take
for you to get that off?
- Oh, I didn't take that
off, I made them do it.
I go, that's real cute,
when I get outta my room, that
(beep) better be off my car.